Joe do you practice every day do you
have to play guitar every day to stay
good or at this point are you such a
master that you could go weeks without
playing well none of that Howard I play
every day just to play and every once in
a while I play something that I didn't
think about playing or mean to play and
I trip on it there they go
what was that every time I do that it's
part of a new song and when I got 10 of
those that's how I write music you
record it real quick or do you memorize
it I'm always recording but he has a
great memory he does yeah but we were
just working on a song the other weekend
it's like we were at the out at dinner
yeah
and with Jim Keltner and Van Dyke Parks
and clubs Foreman was in LA but it okay
and you got all at dinner to go and
we're sitting around and I said
something like but you got to get off to
get down ah he calls me the next that's
a great yeah that's very John wall's
gonna watch the guy and so now we're
writing that song will you guys go into
a studio and and Ringo you'll play drums
and Joe will and you lay down this track
exactly you got to get up to get down
yeah I like it yeah
oh wait till you hear what he says what
do you mean well now we're gonna mention
you Ringo do you still play the drums
every day no no I never did I never
wanted to practice on my own I couldn't
I can't stand it he practiced really
good we shall play with no you don't
lose it's like a bike Ronnie I feel it's
like a bike I have no pleasure in
sitting there on my own Boom Boom Bang
but Ringo does going to take tremendous
strength you have to have power to play
drums it works out every day yeah I
don't work out to play drums but you
know you don't need a lot of strength
you just you know the sticks on that
heavy you know I'm pressing like 10 or
15 pounds